hello my name is scott nelio i am a
medical oncologist at the national
institute of health
uh in bethesda maryland and today i will
be talking about
the clinical development of
immunotherapy in euroville cancer
whenever i talk about drug development
or cancer in general
i i always like to break it down simple
and then
expand it to the more complex and i
think these
three main areas always are my starting
points when discussing drug development
uh we start with the anatomical location
or the
the largest the macroscopic area of a
tumor
and then going down further to the
histology
and the histology overlaps with the
cellular
molecular characteristic genetic
characteristics
of cancer and including the
the tumor micro environment
now when talking about urophil cancer or
uretal track cancer um
starting out with the anatomy or the
anatomical location
uh the the urethral
lining uh goes all the way up from the
the
renal pelvis um down the ureter
into the bladder and to the urethra
this lining can cause it can become a
ligand at any point
leading to urethral cancer when talking
about urothelial cancer
it you can't speak about urethral cancer
really without talking about bladder
cancer
the majority of urethral cancer
occur within the bladder so sometimes
when
i talk about urethral you may hear me
switching off between the words bladder
and urethel but
it's because the majority of urethral
cancer
occur in the bladder itself
when staging uh urethel carcinoma
and particularly in the bladder um
really the main
point is to look at of whether it is
non-muscle invasive uh muscle invasive
or beyond that advanced or metastatic uh
the bladder itself
uh comprises of an epithelium and
suboptimal connective tissue the laminar
propria
as well as uh the muscle beneath that
the muscularis propria
the layer below the muscle is the uh
paravesticular fat um so the tumor can
start out very small
as a ta or t1 uh without invading the
muscle
in a non-muscle invasive setting or and
then can extend towards the muscle
then becoming a t2 um
this staging comes in uh uh this staging
uh
is important for various reasons one
prognosis
uh non-muscle invasive biologic cancer
holds up far better prognosis than
uh than that of uh metastatic uh
and also different treatment options uh
non-muscle invasive
bladder cancer would uh lend to more
localized treatments
whereas once it's into the muscle um
a cystectomy is we're taking out the
bladder as needed and for metastatic
the disease is no longer curable but
treatable
with systemic therapies like
chemotherapy
and immunotherapy
and just touching a little bit on
bladder cancer epidemiology
in the u.s there's 81 000 new cases and
17 000 deaths occur
each year due to bladder cancer and
there's multiple risk factors
including smoking chemical dyes
rubbers and textile paints
and now talking more about just the
general histology and the histology that
i'm going to focus on is urophil
carcinoma
up top uh it's right here
uh but when we're talking about the
bladder um
ninety percent of the bladder cancers
are going to be urathio carcinoma
histology
uh the remaining uh lesser uh
common histologies are going to be
squamous cell carcinoma
adenocarcinoma and small cell with other
rarer variants
such as sarcoma melanoma and even
lymphoma
urethel cancer has gone a very long time
without much drug development um
1978 we had a breakthrough uh
with cisplatin and when i talk about the
drug development timeline i'm going to
be talking about
mainly systemic therapies um
then in 1985 uh we got mvac
with meth the combination of
methotrexate then blastine
adriamycin and cysplatin
uh in 2000 we got the addition of
genocitamine to cisplatin
um and then really nothing really
happened
other than maybe adding carboplatin but
till 2016 and 2017
uh when we had a breakthrough of five
additional
uh immunotherapy pd-1 and pdl-1
checkpoint inhibitors and that included
a tesla as a map
a value map your value map pemberlism
app
and the volume map um
this slide has had been updated recently
because
while these two are not immunotherapy we
did have two additional drugs added in
2019 for the treatment uradial cancer
and that's informed about bendotin an
antibody drug conjugate
connected for and an erdofitanib
which is a targeted fgfr3
inhibitor
but for this talk i will be focusing on
the
develop the drug development course of
uh the checkpoint inhibitors
specifically the pd1 pdl1 inhibitors
in advanced or metastatic urethral
cancer
and here are the five uh approved immune
checkpoint inhibitors in uh bladder
cancer
and for the pd100 there's a pemberlism
adam the volume map
pdl1 inhibitors there's a tesla's map a
volume evander value map
all five of these are approved uh in the
second line
setting uh after progressing on
cisplatin
um their pembrolizumab and tesla
elizumab
are approved also uh for those that are
uh unable to in uh receive cisplatin
in the first line um with a caveat of
having pdl1 expression
and i'll also discuss further recently
pembrolizumab was
moved up even in the earlier setting
with fda approval in non-muscle invasive
bladder cancer
okay uh so to briefly go through
uh uh the mechanism of pdl1
and pd1 inhibition
tumor cells and even regular cells in
your body are going to have put out
uh expression of a receptor pdl-1
uh and it's an it induces an inhibitory
signal to a t
cell when it binds to td-1 pd1 receptor
when also binding an antigen in a t cell
receptor
so uh when a t cell comes around
and sees pdl1 on a tumor cell uh
theoretically it's inhibited from
actually uh
killing or inducing cell death into that
tumor cell
however when you block it with a pd1 or
pdl1 inhibitor
the t cell is able to recognize the
antigen
uh with its t cell receptor and
therefore recognize the tumor cell as a
foreign invader
and induce cell death
and briefly before i get through uh the
upcoming studies it's important to
talk about uh the side effects of immune
checkpoint inhibitors which are
are very broad um and i mean checkpoint
inhibitor can cause essentially an
inflammation or autoimmune reaction
throughout the entire body
uh most common would be inflammation of
the lungs with pneumonitis colitis
dermatitis hepatitis but
it really can cause inflammation
anywhere with even the kidneys nephritis
bone marrow suppression as well as
glandular autoimmune toxicities
thyroid induced diabetes
and even neurologic side effects
autoimmune to the nerves and even to the
brain
causing meningitis and encephalitis
the majority of breakthroughs in pd1 and
pdl1 inhibition
have occurred in the metastatic setting
in urethral cancer so that i will talk
about that and some of the pivotal
studies that have occurred
the first uh major study to come out was
published in nature
uh which was looking at the activity of
uh
at the time called mpdl 3280
a or now known as a tesla ismab
the anti-pd1 anti-pdl-1
treatment and metastatic bladder cancer
and here's a list a summary of
pd1 and pl1 inhibitors approved
uh in the second line setting after
receiving cisplatin therapy
and some of the the pivotal studies uh
the javelin study for evaluate
phase 1b headed by andre apollo at the
nih
uh as well as the checkmate uh 3032
studies for nivolumab
uh study 1108 for devolumab
and the two phase threes uh
in figure 211 uh for a tesla is a map
and keynote 45 um
this uh going forward i'm just going to
focus on
the keynote 45 uh for uh
leading to pemberlism that approval
so uh in uh march 20th 2017
pembrolizumab was um
they published the study of pembroken
acceptable one therapy for uh your ideal
cancer
czech 42 542 patients with banter
european cancer
that recurred or progressed after
platinum therapy received pembro
for three weeks 200 milligrams
uh verse investigative choice
chemotherapy of either paclitaxel
dosatexyl or benflumine
and here this slide is showing the the
pretty balanced
nature of the demographics between the
pembrolizumab
and the chemotherapy groups
and pembrolizumab when compared to
chemotherapy
showed an overall survival benefit of
10.3 months
versus 7.4 months which was
statistically
significant
and this held up in the two-year
review
um and when talking about uh fd
about uh fda approvals um
then i should mention june 19 2018 the
fda
uh limited the use of teas map
map for some urethial cancers
specifically
um using in the first one setting versus
platinum ineligible
patients uh who were pdl one negative
uh due to uh poor uh results
okay
and so those are the main studies uh
for uh leading to the approvals for the
indications
of the the pd1 and pdl1 inhibitors
in the second line setting pureville
carcinoma
now there's been a lot of great studies
done recently and i'm going to talk
about some of those as well
so uh the studies i've shown you up
front have all looked at
giving the standard of care primary
cis platinum first for patients with
advanced or metastatic urethral cancer
followed by a checkpoint inhibitor
a pd1 or pdl1 inhibitor
and then um
in in between that um first receiving
the chemotherapy and then looking for
progression and then
giving the checkpoint inhibitor this
study
asked the question of whether or not you
can give the
checkpoint inhibitor immediately after
giving
the chemotherapy
and so patients with metastatic urethral
cancer achieving at least stable disease
on first-line platinum-based
chemotherapy enrolled
patients are randomly assigned to a
double-blind one-to-one to switch
maintenance pembro 200 milligrams
iv once every three weeks versus placebo
for up to 24 months
patients with disease progression on
placebo cross over to pembroke
and the primary objective was determined
progression free survival and the
secondary objectives include determining
overall survival as well as treatment
outcomes according to pdl1
combined composite score
and when you look at the switch
maintenance study um comparing uh
patients that received the pembrolizumab
uh
and switch maintenance for placebo
obviously they had a higher
overall response rate of uh 23 percent
in the uh
pembro sorry 23 in the pembrolizumab
group
and 10 in the placebo group
and progression free survival was
significantly longer with maintenance
pembroke versus placebo
5.4 months versus 3 months
and that also asks the question of
whether or not you combine chemotherapy
up front
with a checkpoint inhibitor and that's
what this study in vigor 130 looked at
uh which was a tesla-ism lab with or
without chemotherapy and metastatic
urethral cancer
i was a multi-center randomized
placebo-controlled phase 3.
and here's the study schema of invigor
130
so patients with locally advanced uh or
metastatic urethral cancer
were randomized to either arm a rb or mc
our arm a had a tesla mat plus uh
platinum
and gem cytobeam uh carbo or cisplatin r
b had
uh teslas and monotherapy and rmc was
uh placebo plus uh platinum plus gem
cytome
and when comparing uh tis alizumab plus
a platinum-based
uh chemotherapy uh to the placebo
uh plus the platinum chemotherapy
therapy in the first line setting there
was
a uh a uh approval in progression-free
survival of 8.2 versus 6.3 months
uh another interesting study was looking
at um
the combination of a cla4 inhibitor plus
a p1 or pdl1
checkpoint inhibitor and this is an
expansion uh cohort of checkmate 32
and this was looking at uh
patients that uh were who had metastatic
urethral cancer
uh in an open label multicore study were
true with either the volume out of three
milligrams per kilogram monotherapy
every two weeks
um or the volume at three milligrams per
kilogram
plus it'd be one milligram per kilogram
every three weeks for four doses
uh followed by never monotherapy or
nevo monotherapy three milligrams per
kilogram every two weeks
uh plus uh
uh plus uh
ipam the three milligrams per kilogram
every three weeks
uh followed by nebo uh monotherapy three
milligrams per kilogram
so there's the neva 3 arm the nevo 3
plus ip1 an amiibo one plus ip3 i
apologize if any of that
correctly uh just in the last 30 seconds
so looking at the uh overall response
and since this was an
open label expansion cohort um
able to really look at the uh overall
response rates and the nevo one plus mp3
had a higher overall response rate than
just nebo alone with 35
versus 20 and higher than the nevo 3 it
be one at 28
um and it really um uh is hypothesis
generating whether or not
um to use nevo one or e3
um these aren't statistically
significant but if you look at the chart
the graph here
um you can look at the progression free
of uh nevo3 uh alone nevo three plus it
be one or
nevo one plus a d3 um and
the the curve for the nevo one at b3
might be a little bit higher
so while this isn't a uh a immunotherapy
itself it uh it's hard to not talk about
uh infortabindotin
um or in that matter talking about what
could we add to immunotherapy
uh to improve it um informative
endothelin is one of those drugs which
is an antibody drug
with mmae the antibodies targets the
cell hesitation model method for
and currently it's fda approved and
advanced or metastatic european cancer
after
chemotherapy and immunotherapy so in the
third line setting
and recently at gu asco they published
some very exciting results of study
ev103
and this was looking at a patient
population of uh
urothelial cancer of locally advanced or
metastatic urethral cancer
and a dose escalation study of
information plus pembrolizumab
um within ford map the dotenon days one
and
uh eight and pebbles on day one of every
three week cycle
and the overalls response rate was
exceptionally high at a 73.3 percent
um so it's very interesting and uh
looking forward to seeing this
combination
in the future and future results from
this
now while i mainly spoke about um
well mainly i talked about treatment of
euro cancer in the metastatic setting
um it's hard not to talk about uh the
other fda approval for immunotherapy and
urethral cancer
and that is uh pembrolizumab and
non-muscle invasive
uh bladder cancer and that was
um seen in keynote uh
057 patients with histologically
confirmed high-risk
bcg unresponsive carcinoma c2 with or
without papillary disease
received adequate bcg therapy and were
unable or unwilling to undergo radical
cystectomy
receive pemberlismab 200 milligrams q3
weeks
for 24 months or until recurrence
progression or acceptable toxicity
patients with high risk non-muscle
invasive bladder cancer or progressive
disease during treatment were
required to discontinue and
out of 103 patients and separate into
cohort a had a complete response rate of
38.8
and among 40 patients who received a
complete response at three months 72.5
maintain that uh complete response at
the last follow-up and that led to the
fda approval
of pembrolizumab for pgcg unresponsive
high-risk non-muscle-invasive bladder
cancer
on january 8th of 2020.
uh and then lastly i just want to touch
on a couple potential biomarkers
one that's been looked at is a pdl one
expression
and currently other than cisplatin
ineligible in the first line of
pembrolizumab
or a tesla is a map um there's
no clinical use at this point of pdl1
testing
in the second line um uh setting
um tumor rotational burden something's
being looked at and so his dna damage
repair
response and dna damage response and
repair gene alterations
uh and so looking at
study here second
so uh teo and the group moral thing
hetering looked at alterations in dna
their uh dna damage response and repair
genes as potential marker for clinical
benefit of pd-1
l1 blockage in advanced european cancer
and they
and they looked at three different
clinical trials
that they had patients on for checkpoint
inhibitors
and used their uh in-house sequencing
msk impact
uh to determine if they had dna damage
repair alterations
and they found those that had dna damage
uh
repair had a higher response to the pdl1
inhibitors
pd-1 pdl1 inhibitors and
when you looked at the overall survival
those would delterious
dna damage repair mutations
seem to do better with checkpoint
inhibitor and just overall patients with
ddr mutations did better than those
without
a another uh another potential biomarker
that's been investigated has been tumor
mutational burden
um and uh here in this study
patients that had a higher tumor
mutational burden
seem to have a better response than
those that didn't
and again currently two mutational
burden
and dna damage repair
do not have a clinical or fda
uh indication for using when prescribing
drugs
and so when looking at european cancer
um we've come
a long way since uh we've initially uh
got cisplatin in 1978 uh and there's a
lot to expand on currently
uh with um uh making checkpoint
inhibitors better
um because even right now uh in the
second line setting response rates
you know around 20 and we can definitely
do much better than that
um by either adding in combination um as
you've seen even
chemotherapy uh other targeted agents
um oh or
um or or other immunotherapies and
vaccines
uh and during this time like one i want
to thank
every single essential worker uh who's
out there on the front lines in the
during the coca-19 uh pandemic
and especially those in new york city
and at mount sinai hospital
where i trained